bureau du centre de dijon il est encore
tôt l'ambiance est tranquille mais le
flot des votants est régulier
beaucoup d'entre eux sont venus ce matin
pour pouvoir vaquer à d'autres activités
ensuite libéré de ce devoir important
pour eux
on s'est battu pour avoir le droit de
vote faut quand même le respecter et
puis en plus faut donner notre peau
parce que si on donne pas neutre on ne
parle pas de rouspéter je pensais que
l'autre que d'autres personnes on est
dans une société
d'épouvantables donc il faut une société
un baiser
[Musique]
protéger de tous les excès face à ces
électeurs juste avant de passer dans
l'isoloir 12 bulletins avec les noms des
douze candidats un choix difficile à
faire chacun a donc dû trouver sa
solution une petite feuille des
thématiques et j'ai noté le chaque fois
envisagé qu'on dirait j'ai pris celui
qui avait la meilleure note à la fin
donc on lui a préféré n'est n'est pas
malheureusement ne pourrait plus avoir
ces ces voix c'est signature mais bon
sinon je pas de difficulté choisi
par élimination je me suis un peu
renseigné quand même votre pas on sait
pas tout loupé quoi
je me suis tout simplement pencher sur
je n'ai pas refait il ya deux mois
j'aurais fait dans la semaine et voilà
eux désormais sont tranquilles et vont
pouvoir profiter de ce dimanche
ensoleillé pour les autres il reste
encore quelques heures les bureaux de
vote fermeront à 19h